( music)
- Thank you Timberley.
While we are locating my four
slide presentation, excellent.
That was Kimberly's nice
way of conveying the fact
that I constantly bitch
about Canvas, all the time.
And, to start with and to just
say that this is what I do.
It does support foreign languages,
but only to a certain extent.
What is that certain extent?
It does not support, I'm sorry Timberley,
but I've been listening to
how amazing that system is
for an hour and a half now.
Also, I do function with
very few hours of sleep.
So, I will stick to my notes
to the best of my ability.
So, in the comment section,
and this is significant.
It does not support the foreign language.
So, either correct your students,
and problems, or mistakes,
in English, or find all
sorts of various ways of not
using any punctuation marks,
or many other thing that just,
it doesn't cut it.
So, this is our aim and attempt to,
an appeal to the Canvas
Gods to make it slightly
more foreign language friendly.
But with that, everything
I present here to today,
I should credit.
In addition to the Hebrew
program, very specifically,
Orit here is my colleague
who is a Canvas genius.
So, whenever I am stuck with something,
I always go to her.
What I wanted to do is take
a step back and briefly
talk a little bit about
homework and why homework
is so significant in foreign language
education in particular.
I took Timberley’s advice, as I always do,
very seriously.
I had no visuals related
to that, except for two.
So, I just randomly added
pictures of Israel made by a
very talented photographer.
His name is Udi Goren,
happens to be my cousin.
(audience laughing)
So, Yale had a strong
commitment to liberal arts
education as we all know.
And part of it is the
foreign language requirement.
That means that every
student who comes to Yale
has to take a foreign language.
It doesn't matter what their
level in a certain language is.
They can choose to take a new language.
They can decide to expand their knowledge
in an existing language.
But, in any event, each and
every one of them is taking
at least one course in a foreign language.
Hebrew, as many other languages
that were presented here today,
Arabic included, and Korean,
of course, is what is called the less,
or considered the less
commonly taught language.
That means that we don't,
unlike the more commonly taught
languages, Spanish, for example,
I always blame them for everything.
We do not have very good textbooks.
So, we have to glean our
pedigogical materials
from different sources.
And, this is where Canvas
is very, very effective.
There's one other issue,
and this, I will have
to actually look at it,
and this is the difficult level
of foreign languages in general.
There is a division we should
took it with a grain of salt,
but generally speaking, Hebrew belongs
to a category four level language.
And that is, the division was made by the
Foreign Service Institute
of the U.S. Department of the State.
And that means that in order
to achieve an advanced level,
advanced meaning actual
scale, and it's called an RS
in their scale, a student needs
of have 1100 contact hours
in the language.
Now, if you do a simple
math, because this is all
that I am capable of
being from the humanities,
at Yale, we teach five hours
a week for, say 26 weeks,
if we exclude exams and things like that.
But, this is actually include those hours,
so that's 130 hours a year.
Lets say that the student
is highly committed,
and they take eight
semesters of the language.
We're still even less than
half of where we should be
in order to have them reach that level.
That means that we really
need to rely on homework,
and on work done outside of classroom.
And to that end, I want
to just show how we use,
in the Hebrew program, we use Canvas.
And again, I credit Orit
for this beautiful idea
of dividing courses into weeks.
So students, yes, they do have to count,
but only to 13.
And therefore know when
they are in each week,
but once we press, they
have all the work that they
need to do, it's also
convenient for me if I want to
embed and show certain clips in classes.
I don't have to go back to my
email and get it from there.
I just click and it's there.
And then, at the end of every
class, it's always in green,
because that's kind of how I like.
And, it's not as intimidating as red.
They press and they have
list of everything they need
to do for homework.
No, that's not that.
Why is it significant?
Because here you can see,
they have six different
homework assignments.
And they need to know
where to get things from.
And, when we have everything in one place,
they just click and get
to where they need to be.
So, it functions very
much like the modules,
only it incorporates many other sources.
Yeah, I'm good.
In addition to sending
them to specific website,
I also here, send them to
the specific assignments
that they need to respond to.
And here I will end with
just one minor complaint,
last one.
Because they have to basically
submit even different things
for each class, sometimes they don't do
those things at once.
The problem is that when
they upload the material,
they need to upload everything together,
so if they have seven files, for example,
if we sent them to do some
online activity and then
I asked them to do a
screenshot of the activity,
so that I know that
they've done it, and also,
what went wrong, what was good, et cetera,
they have to submit everything at once.
Because if they do it in
two times, for example,
the first time gets erased.
So, we do need something.
We need something else for
them, improve and take care of.
Other than that, been working
with Canvas for two years,
I do like it.
I don't tell Kimberly that,
but it is much more convenient,
and straight forward
once you get the hang
of it than class V2 was.
And the team is highly professional,
and responsive to the
extent that they can.
So, at least they will hear
you complain about things,
and say, "Yes, yes, we are working on it.
"We promise to make it better."
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
( music)